très bon bilan sachant qu'on n'est pas
l'une des plus grandes fédérations on
est même au niveau dom-tom la plus jeune
fédération puisque la fédération de la
réunion de la guadeloupe ou même de la
guyane ont déjà quasiment une vingtaine
d'années d'existence voire même plus
nous on a on célèbre no 8 ans et je
trouve que en huit ans il ya eu vraiment
un gros travail de la part des
professeurs ils sont 17 qui sont
fédérées cette année à la cnd martini un
gros travail de la part des professeurs
un gros travail de la part des candidats
qui sont de plus en plus nombreux chaque
année on enregistre une augmentation de
10% concours régional et surtout une
belle représentation de la région
concours national puisque cette année on
enregistre quand même des prix trois
premiers prix à félicitations trois
premiers prix à lunas et onze premiers
prix 1er prix nationaux donc ça
représente quand même sur le panel
entier des candidats qui se sont
déplacés une belle représentation d'al
arich
que va-t-il se passer maintenant pour
6 voilà exactement six candidats lancy
ce passage que précisément parce qu'il
ya des groupes il ya des duos y compris
dedans ils ont la possibilité de
participer ils sont à ce moment-là
sélectionnés pour le concours européen
qui en est à sa deuxième année
d'existence puisqu'il a été démarré par
la cnd l'année dernière qui se fera au
luxembourg du 29 du 28 au 29 septembre
2019 voilà donc ça c'est une proposition
qui leur est faite c'est pas du tout une
obligation toujours un petit peu pour
les mêmes raisons financières et tout le
plus souvent tout cas l'année dernière
tous ceux qui avaient été sélectionnés
il était allé on avait effectivement
ramener un deuxième prix européen pour
l'élève en classique dont julie carraz
qui avaient participé et qu'il y an
d'ailleurs qui sait représenter cette
année et qui a à nouveau eu la
possibilité de participer à l'european
corps une fois cette année donc la
préparation
exact on est reparti en mode préparation